so my dad he broke the world record for
the longest distance traveled in 24
hours by human power walking no he was
on a bike okay he engineered a recumbent
bicycle which is like a lay down bike
yeah and he rode it on a track for 24
hours holy [ __ ] and broke the world
world record he was in the Guinness Book
of World Records one year like I used to
get that book every year for Christmas
as a kid and then one year my dad was a
full color picture of my dad standing
beside the bike how did he [ __ ]
coolest thing ever for a child did they
show up to the track and like watch him
do it I think there was someone there
from Guinness he just lied yeah yeah no
he didn't actually do it no well no
wonder you're a [ __ ] beast when it
comes to running swimming well that's
like part of the reason why it like it
makes me happy because I feel like it's
kind of in my blood yeah it's like I was
raised around it and seeing it so much
so now it feels kind of like I was meant
to do it yeah